uh i just want to start with uh what i'm
sure you're hearing from everyone which
is you did such a fantastic job with
this it is awesome to get to talk to you
about the movie i just want to start
with congratulations um
so uh but i wanna i like asking the
curveball at the beginning i promise
it's not hard hitting um if someone has
actually never seen anything that you've
done before as an actor what's the first
thing you want them to watch and why
obviously i have made things that i'm
less proud of in my life as an actress
but i always feel like there you know
there's there's touchstones all the way
through oh this worked oh this worked oh
this worked and then this worked you
know and obviously in between there are
some where you're like oh those ones
didn't work i know and um i usually feel
that the latest thing i did is the most
accurate
articulation of who i am
um
i mean really i know as a kind of a
strange like avoiding your question but
uh
i don't act in um the lost daughter but
it's a totally a continuation of my work
and my ideas and
um
and i do think it's
the thing i would want anyone who wanted
to know about me to watch
i i
completely agree and understand um what
was it about this material though that
said i have to make this
i think it was just how truthful it was
truthful in like a kind of unconscious
way it was a reliable
ground to stand on
i think when i read ferrante and i read
um the neapolitan novels first um and
then days of abandonment and then i read
the last daughter but when i was reading
uh those books and i remember in
particular when i first read the first
one
i was like
i had never heard some of these truthful
things articulated before things about
in particular i think being a woman in
the world a mother yes but also a being
a lover a thinker an artist
um and i didn't even know how much i
needed to hear them and and i feel like
in a way as a as a culture we've made an
agreement not to talk about really big
aspects of ourselves and ferrante broke
the agreement and that kind of
shattering of something i found really
invigorating
really
um some sort of terrifying but also very
exciting and
i thought
what if instead of having an experience
like that alone in my room with a book i
mean i literally dropped days of
abandonment another book of hers when i
was reading it i was like [ __ ] this book
you know like it was like too much and
and i thought what if instead of
of having these feelings alone and i
also knew i wasn't alone feeling this
way because women i mean people all over
the world i mean like her books were
like flying off the shelves
what if i could put it on screen and it
could be
first of all
a communal experience where you're
hearing these truths actually hearing
them actually seeing them expressed
on screen and you might be sitting next
to
your mother or your husband or
your daughter
um that seemed to me like a really
radical
and
exciting thing to try to do
i i commend you so much for bringing
this to the screen because i've had
conversations with people that are raw
and honest and it's never depicted in a
movie the real feelings and the real
things that people go through and that's
what i think your film does just so
brilliantly but i i want to i want to
talk a little bit i love talking about
the editing process because that's
ultimately where the film comes together
so
i've spoken to a lot of first-time
directors and they talk about how
they're very they cherish everything and
they have a tough time letting go of a
great scene or a shot because it's so
perfect but so how was it for you in the
editing room and sort of uh telling this
story
well i'll i mean look i
obviously yes i'm a first-time director
and and yet i've been involved in making
films for so long and you know how many
times i saw my own work cut together and
i was like i wish i could just get in
the [ __ ] editing room you know or or
or some incredible experience we had
which is just not lifted off you know
and um or when i was producing um
working with people who i loved on uh on
the deuce right and i would see cuts of
things before um
before they would go out and i would i
would write you know paragraphs long
essays about why this
orgasm could not be cut because it's a
feminist piece with the orgasm in it you
know whatever but i would i would and i
would have to be i would have to write
them perfectly and be a little funny and
whatever to get what i needed so when i
got into the editing room i was like
oh my god you know like it's mine i can
i can do what i want and
i think i would say
one of the most
incredible collaborations that i had
inside of you know a film that had many
many many exciting collaborations was my
my work with my editor alfonso claves
and um
uh i don't know if i had the problem of
letting go of things i mean basically i
watched his assembly and i was like
oh that's interesting that's not the
movie but that's cool and you know how
could he ever how could he possibly have
known how to
i mean what i mean it's just it's just a
random shot
and then we start laying out the film
that i'm holding in my arms like this
you know
not that i knew exactly how we would cut
it i don't shoot like that i hear about
people who are cutting a film in their
heads or
i know i'm going off now but i just
recently watched um
raising arizona again and i was like
that was probably in some ways cut in a
way as they were shooting right you can
imagine the
the
um storyboards and you can you know me
know i don't work like that but i knew
that
there were these i i did have the story
and the move through it in my head and
these incredibly beautiful things for my
actors
and um but like the basically the first
thing we did fonzie and i was cut the
whole there's like a whole first section
of the movie which is gone we did it
like the first 20 minutes we started
working together i was like no it's not
good enough out you know
there was one scene um
that was very difficult for me to let go
of which was with dagmara jameen chick
who plays cali
and olivia
and it was a beautiful scene and it
didn't work in the movie and um
that was hard there was also um you know
the scene which i love which with uh ed
harris and olivia coleman where
they're
cooking octopus
and eating octopus at the same time
basically that was two separate long
scenes and i remember
you know it was the first time you know
that's maybe two-thirds of the way into
the movie that we'd come across
something we cut it was really you know
beautifully acted it was the scenes i
was really pleased with as a writer you
know we cut it fonzie cut it well and we
looked at it and we were like
this does not work
i don't know why it doesn't work it's
not lifting up
and um fonzie and i had been talking
about don't look now
a couple of days before because it has
that that tone of like
kind of thriller kind of
french movie kind of horror movie you
know and he was like it's it's it's
it's interesting to think about in terms
of the lost daughter which also has
i don't think a similar tone but
also thriller some horror
some french movie um and i had just
watched it and i was like funs
why don't we cut the octopus stuff like
the sex scene and don't look now
you know so so that they're you know
like they're making love and getting
dressed at the same time
and he was like
give me a half an hour and it was
actually the only half an hour that i
didn't sit there in the whole thing i
was like cool and i came back and it was
like
this beautiful
almost magical sequence
i have to stop there i'm just going to
say again
such great work and i really hope you're
making another movie again soon thank
you
thank you
you